this is a partnership this is a parent
right here that surprised a lot of
people this off season I know privately
you guys talked about the possibility of
teaming up did you guys ever think it
would be a reality you know it's on
record saying if I had to play with one
person I play with him our style of play
and who we are as people I think it a
mesh well you always think in your head
oh man I could fit well with this guy
but now you know that he's here I'm
happy that we teammate um happy what it
brings on the table what it brings on on
this team elevates us to a different
level and I'm excited this is the best
team I've ever been a part of having a
guy like him all time great you
understand that in order for us to be
successful we have to work extremely
hard and I think we're both willing to
do that seeing Damen Lillard in a buck
uniform is going to take some getting
used to it it's going to be fascinating
to see how Dame and Giannis played
together what was that first
conversation that first real deep
conversation like with Dame I knew he
was you know flying was on the plane and
then I was trying to monitor his flight
you know I'm not a St sorry but I was
start morning fly you know when he
arrives you know so I had to basically
you know come up here we had the
conversation here The Practice Facility
basically told him like you know I'm
I'm on the same page you know what
I'm saying like whatever you want me to
do I'll do I'm about winning I'm about
sacrifice I'm about putting the work his
day you know and I believe in him
basically I might be sh but this is his
team you know it doesn't matter what
people say yeah this is his team like he
got to lead this because
at the end of the day like for him to
feel successful you got to feel very
comfortable what has the transition been
like you never been in a situation where
you had to be on a different team I mean
it's been it's been different you know
obviously you spend 11 years and in the
same place you build up a certain level
of comfort like I my whole family
basically live in Portland but it's it's
been a a smooth transition the makeup of
the team makes it a lot easier you know
the fact that we got a lot of vets they
love basketball they take this job
serious and I I think in this situation
obviously playing next to him you know
this dude is a two time MVP and a
monster out
[Applause]
thereis how
significant how serious are you about
getting another
championship
well it's what we dream though our whole
life you know being in the The Last Man
Standing and lifting up a trophy and
when they speak the game of basketball
they have to mention your name you force
them to mention your name so I hope this
year we can play the game that I way if
we do that win a championship after a
half century the Milwaukee Bucks are NBA
champions once again the Greek Greek is
a Greek NBA
champion I need it like he got one the
desire to get another one is probably
stronger cuz you know what that feeling
is like it's also like a a certain level
of Freedom that I'm sure he plays with I
don't have that freedom for most of my
career has been a a situation where it
was an opportunity for me to over
achieve I put a lot of pressure on
myself to rise to the occasion to be
able to perform to be able to come up
big and I live my life that way I'm just
excited for the opportunity man it's
been a a long time coming to compete you
know at the highest level level and and
have an opportunity at a championship
and that's all you can ask for